je pense qu'aujourd'hui eric zemmour a
analysé la situation de la france
beaucoup de français s'en sont rendu
compte ce n'est pas pour rien qu
aujourd'hui la 17 pourtant beaucoup de
français le réclame aussi puisqu'il n'a
pas décidé lui même de se lancer là
dedans c'est vraiment le peuple par le
peuple les gens qui croient en lui
qu'ils ont lancés sur les réseaux
sociaux et j'en fais partie
maintenant l'interdire de s'exprimer sur
les plateaux télé je ne pense pas robert
il en parle de maubert et on parle pas
de sens ils ont adhéré bon sens sur le
marché alors on s'entend en fait ça
dépend de la définition de chacun il y
en a qui veulent complètement le
censurer voire peut-être pire
les angles envoyés au goulag peut-être
qu'on sait pas forcément donc j'ai pas
entendu ça non mais peut-être pas
ça va pas tarder à voir
du coup du coup ce qui est reproché à
eric zemmour de ce côté là les
condamnations des propos qui sont jugés
c'est vrai que c'est plutôt à
la justice
et condamné jeu
il a payé voilà il a payé sa dette il y
en a d'autres qui font des agressions
etc qui le disent que c'est des bêtises
ils finissent professeur à l'éducation
nationale ben on l'a encore vu cette
semaine donc je parle du jeune qui est
intervenu avec eric zemmour à drancy
voir revenir sur la sphère de drancy
pour l'instant on fait un premier tour
de table laurence voulu intervenir mais
non pourquoi voilà je réponds non parce
qu'en fait moi je ne soutiens pas eric
zemmour vous le savez je crois je me
bats contre ces idées au quotidien donc
je pense que jamais j'aurais pensé que
des politiques que les journalistes face
à la rigueur se permettent de jouer les
censeurs des adversaires parce qu'il
faut quand même avoir un sacré vide
idéologique et être vraiment excusez moi
au fond du trou pour en arriver à
vouloir faire taire les autres eric
zemmour pourquoi il est beaucoup invité
un parce qu'il ce qu'il dit même si je
ne suis pas d'accord avec lui
intéressent les français parce que
croyez pas qu'on met à la chaîne et
c'est pour ça qu'on met pas poutou des
gens qui n'intéresse pas les français et
puis on l'a entendu longtemps à la télé
dans un créneau de chroniqueurs et là il
arrive dans le monde politique donc
c'est normal qu'ils fassent le dos aux
tournées médias en tant qu'invité
politique ça c'est une question
technique puisque très certainement il
va être candidat à la présidentielle
mais je trouve que d'en arriver à se
poser la question ou à la dircom
monsieur coquerel qu'on doit faire taire
des autres alors que l'extrême gauche
passe à la télé tous les jours dans le
sujet parce qu'ils ont peur
d'oser c'est pareil que cela fait
d'être vos adversaires politiques si
vous n'avez rien à lui répondre en fait
vous faites le sur soi qui était pendant
l'échangé d'otages de votre échec
politique depuis des années et comme
vous n'avez rien à dire